και τα κόμματα έχουν να αποδεκτεί σε κάποιο βαθμόν το ρόλο που τους απέμεινει δηλαδή
ρουσφέρτη διευκολήνσης φοβούνται να δοκιμάσουν κάτι καιουιον μήπως και από τίχοτου ακπυ δεν έχει ξεπεράσει
ακόματ την προεδρία χριστώς μεγάλλον πρόβλημε του σημαγερμού είναι ότι αρχί ζι πληωνή απόσταση της
υγεσίας από τη βάση να μεγαλών να προε όγα τον πρόεδο χριστοδουλίνου θεωρίσε ό ίναι
πρόεδρος μία σητιας τι ου προθούν την ιδέα ε ότιο χρήση το δουλί δης ίναι
προεδροσμίας στη δίας εχαθήρη του χρηστοδουλτη που κάω πρέπει να επαναλαμβάνει ενομίο μέσως πολί της
αρχίζευνακού η ένα μήνυμα στην έκτυπη στην έβδομη φορά που θα το επανώμετούτι η κυβέρνησης
λέει μέσα σε μία ενημέρα πέτε διαφρετικά μήνυματα την άλλη εναι μέρα λέει περιατι άλλα
ταημηνήματα οικός αναστασιάδιξα από για τι συμβολές το αντρια χασιρες ώρες ώρεςώρεςτο νέο που κλίων
είναι μια έρευνα που αφορά πρώτη ανδιαμερικανική διαδήλωσης μετά την σβολή στη λευκωσία στη διαρκια
της οποίας εδολοφωνή τηκε καταμιστηριότι τροπων ο αμερικανός πρέες τη συγκτ ότιτλος στου ιβλίου είνα
μλες και μίλι άλλο έναντε έναλά εκποτκά σήμερα μαζί σας ι διατερητιμή ο σύμβουλος επικοινωνίας
πολιτικός αναλητής δήμωσε ο γράφος γραφέας και πολλά άλλά ο αντρέας οχαριο κυριάπα αδρία μου
ε ευχαριστό πολύ που είσαι μαζί μου σήμερα χαράμ να δούμε λίγο το πολιτικό σκηνικό
πως διαμορφώνεται και όχι μόνο θα δούμε και ποιος είνα αντρέας χάριο κυριάκως να δούμε
ότι φέλσ τελικά ποια είναι μεγάλη αγάπη το αντρέα χραι κυριάοπολιτικός αναλητής σύμβουλος επικοινωνίας σε
γραφέας δημοσιογράφος σε κάθε φάση της ζωής σου είναι και κάτι διαφοριετικό δεξεκινάς καης επάντα
το ίδιο νομίζον σε αυτή ντη φάση της ζήσμου το κομμάτι της συγγραφίς της έρευνας
είναι κάτιπούμε γε μειζί διαίτερα